what are some of the experiences you
mentioned that you haven't mentioned
elsewhere because i'm sure people who
have followed you oh
well no i mean i i it's it's known that
i saw
a craft as a young boy
went right over my head
um
you know 30 40 feet
above me right at tree level
um i had no idea what it was
when it happened i i didn't say oh
there's a ufo
it was silent
silent yeah
um
and
you know it's it was only sometime in my
20s or 30s
that it sort of clicked
i said well that was what you saw
because it always has been with me
you know and the reason it was with it
is with me because i went around to the
other
people in the neighborhood who to whom i
was delivering papers at the time
and uh
i said you know did you see this
and i explained it to them and they just
kind of looked at me like okay kid
here's your paper money you know go away
um
so that's uh
you know
that's what drives me
which is why i would you know call
myself an experiencer because i'm
looking to explain what it is that i saw
you know it isn't to me proof of
anything
but
it's
it's to me something that
shook me to my core
at the time did it when you were a kid
even yeah
yeah i mean
it it was just like this
how do you explain it you just say what
was that
so you remember when we talked about
that there are some people who
experience seeing some phenomenon or
some element
and there are some people who didn't who
are right beside them now in that were
there some people or was it just an
individual who saw and then others
didn't where what i'm asking for was in
was there inter-subjective agreement
between at least more than one person
yes yeah oh yeah in some other cases
absolutely
yeah i mean
i mean the the the council bluffs case
is is the one in point where there were
like three individuals from different
vantage points around the town of
council bluffs that all saw the same
thing
a a a glowing blinking object that then
dropped something
bright
to the ground and it was bright because
it was molten metal
and then they all arrived at the same
time pretty much and the police showed
up
uh thinking it was a plane crash
and there was a blob there was a giant
blob of molten metal on the ground and
we got the pictures and everything
uh the original pictures kind of
unfortunately those those uh polaroids
feign go faint over time actually if
there's a if there's a person out there
who knows how to restore old polaroids
to enhance the original colors
that was there it would be nice to for
them to reach out to me